well it's impossible for someone like me
um brown person in in in Britain not to
be um brought into the topic of race
it's you know I I live the topic of race
but I came to Britain when I was about
six and the Britain I grew up in was
very different from the Britain it is
today in those days racism was vicious
um visceral in a way that's barely
imaginable now um RAC attacks were daily
and it's hard to think of a of a time I
didn't come back from school having been
in a fight um racism drew me into
politics I got involved in a whole host
of campaigns um about deportations about
racist attacks about um racism in the
workplace and so on but if it was racism
that Drew me into politics it was
politics that made me see beyond racism
to see um that there were broader issues
of social justice and that um thinking
about social justice simply in terms of
my experiences was
insufficient um I came to read people
like Marx and Mill um Baldwin and arent
um who drew me into an entirely
different Universe began to see um the
world in in in a different in a
different
way and it was at that time um the left
was still what one might call the
Universalist left there was still
universally strands to um the idea that
uh what we were fighting for uh was not
simply shaped by one's
identity but had
um was about creating coalitions and
movements that went across identities um
and that it only in transforming
everybody's lives that one gets to
transform one's own life
um but you know within about this we're
talking about here about the early 1980s
MH but within about a
decade much of that had changed that
um the the left became much more rooted
in identitarian Notions the the big
issue for me was the salon rushy
campaign MH um in 1988 1989 um which um
where a lot of my friends who'd been on
the
left um suddenly became opponents of
rushi uh thought he satanic versus
should be censored um supported the the
burning of the
book um and it got me to thinking about
what had happened why that was the case
why the left has changed so much um and
it got me thinking about identitarian
politics and that's what I've been
thinking about and arguing against for
the best part of 30 years yeah
so one thing that's interesting about
this is is I I'm American and and you're
you grew up in Manchester and have lived
in London for a very long
time and there are striking similarities
between how the conversation has evolved
in America and in Britain we've seen the
same move from a Universalist
left uh from a left in America that
could really claim to live by Martin
Luther King's you know Universalist
message of we are all brothers in Christ
there is neither Greek nor Jew black nor
white he would say things like that to a
a left that is much more focused on as
you call it stay in your lane arguments
which I think is a great summary of the
ethos of the left right if you're black
stay in your black Lane if you're white
stay in your White Lane if you're
Mexican stay you know that we all have
these racial lanes and and roles to play
and beliefs and politics that come sort
of as a package deal with the race or
ethnicity that you're born
into and that's often called identity
politics uh there also differences
though between America and and the
UK one which is
that uh in America we had you know
slavery within our own
borders and you know often that
historical episode is at the center of
some of our uh deepest
controversies um and the other
difference is that we've long been a
nation of immigrants a nation with
massive immigration in the mid 19th
century um and and so I guess the
pattern of immigration and backlash and
more immigration and backlash is old is
very old in America but it's I think
it's newer um in in the UK I'm curious
how you view the differences between
America and the UK when it comes to the
issue of racial
identity I think one of the problems we
have is that um because of the economic
social cultural heft of
America what happens in America tends to
shape what happens elsewhere so
attitudes about race arguments about
race in America are simply taken on and
applied uh to other countries where
they're less applicable um one of the
reasons um that the book concentrates on
America is precisely that that um
because the the the arguments about race
in America are are so influential uh to
the rest of the world that um that it's
important to to challenge it in its own
terms uh to unpick them um and therefore
to uh show why they they not so
applicable not just in in the rest of
the world but to America itself um
I think that the identitarian strain is
probably much stronger in America than
it is elsewhere I mean you can see it
elsewhere but it is probably much
stronger in America um and to me to
explain the the shift to an identitarian
turn you have to understand two things
firstly
that anti-racist movements anti Colonial
movements have always had an
identitarian aspect to them um there's
always been a tension within um
anti-racist movements um between
identitarian and Universalist
perspectives so you know you go back to
the 19th century and you have the back
back to Africa movements in America um
and then you have Marcus Garvey in the
early 20th century negritude pan
africanism and so on so th those have
always been there but not till
relatively recently have they become the
dominant Force within um anti-racist
discourse and the reason they've become
the dominant force is I think to do
with the social pessimism that has
developed over the last uh half
century to to to adopt a Universalist
perspective to think that you can build
coalitions across the fissures of race
and class and ethnicity and so on to
think that you can radically transform
Society requires a certain degree of
optimism social
optimism and much of that has ebbed over
the last uh uh half century so more and
more people cling on to what they have
they cling on to their particular
identities their particular the boxes
into which we've been put and and see
the world more and more through those
identities through those boxes so I
think it's important to to to locate
where we are um it's not as if we've
suddenly become all identitarians it's
always been there but that the wider
shifts The Wider economic political
social shifts um and in particular the
way that um the labor movement has lost
uh influence has lost force over the
past half century it's played an
important part in in in what we're
seeing
now so let's rewind um a lot of your
book deals with the history of the idea
of race this idea
of of humanity being separated into five
or six distinct groups that concept has
not been around forever it has an origin
story like any other idea does and and
so I'm
curious uh in your view when did the
idea of race begin and how did it evolve
from its first state into what it is
today that's obviously a very big
question I make the argument that and
lots of people have made this argument
of course that race is a product of
modernity um it's not that in Pre in the
premodern world there wasn't bigotry or
there wasn't a sense a belief that other
groups may have been subhuman um there
wasn't uh a lack of huge intolerance
um against other groups clearly there
was but there what there wasn't was a
sense that um humans were equal and
there was a single Universal uh uh sense
of
humanity that was what developed largely
in the 18th
century um we think about the
Enlightenment and Enlightenment Notions
of equality and
universalism and against the background
of society is that broadly accept the
idea of equality of universality the
notion of race racism the notion of um
inequality racial inequality becomes
something very
different um what you have from the from
the late 18th century onwards is our our
societies um that are rooted in the idea
that all humans are equal all men are
equal as the American declarations of of
Independence broadly says um or the uh
French uh Declaration of Rights of Man
which broadly says much the same um so
the idea of equality becomes a defining
feature of uh post Enlightenment
societies uh Western
societies but that um abstract belief in
equality is set against the practice
of inequality the social practice of
inequality of
enslavement of um the refusal to uh
Grant uh rights to women to um
minorities to uh working class and so
on and race develops in the modern world
um out of that contradiction as a way of
almost of making sense of that
contradiction
that race becomes a way of saying um
certain people are by Nature
unequal um and therefore not deserving
or not worthy of
equality um and that became an
explanation for slavery for instance it
w black people the ancestors of today's
African-Americans weren't enslaved
because they were black slavery has
existed well before modernity um and it
and it in and both blacks and whites
were enslaved in those days so the the
ancestors of today's African-Americans
weren't enslaved because they were black
but they came to be deemed as racially
distinct and racially inferior as black
people as a way of justifying their
their enslavement so race becomes a
means of of explaining and justifying
the the continuation of inequalities in
societies that
had that had proclaimed their their
Fidelity to
equality and what's important to
recognize is how different say 19th
century views of race were then um
contemporary views of race we think of
race largely in terms of skin color or
continent of origin black white asian
and so on MH whereas for 19 century
thinkers race was
primarily a a description of social
inequalities so yes black people Asians
Chinese Indians and so on we were seen
as inferior but so was the working class
I mean it may be difficult to to to to
comprehend now but 19th century thinkers
saw Factory workers and and uh Farm
hands as racially distinct from
themselves MH as many see white and
black um as racially distinct um and
their inability to be any more than
Factory workers or Farm hands was
attributed to the fact that they were
racially inferior yeah so there's a few
things there one is the difference
between an ethnic group and a
race there as you point out in the book
at that time ethnic groups often viewed
themselves and talked about themselves
as distinct races um you know people
that would be considered the same race
today like the the Irish and the British
or the Normans and um you know the
GS people that would all be described
today or seen as as white at the time
had you know bitter hostility rivalries
and conceptions of themselves as
different
races on the other hand I do feel that
there is a difference between
ethnic differences and and racial
differences which is that the more that
people look very different um at a
glance the easier it is for those
hostilities to persist over very long
periods of time and then the harder it
is for groups to truly meld into one so
for example the Enlightenment thinkers
some of the Enlightenment thinkers that
I admire and I'm sure you do too like
Frederick Douglas one of the major
things they were wrong about and the
case of Douglas is that they thought by
now there would be no such thing as
black people and white people that we
would have intermarried and intermingle
to such a point where we would all kind
of look like a fairly undifferentiated
Mass yet the the patterns of people
looking different and an you know based
on where their ancestors are from has
persisted to to a degree that they
didn't predict
right um and it seems to me you know
when we talk about how ethnic groups in
the American case which I know the most
about such as Irish Americans Italian
Americans polish Americans
Etc by now white Americans my age they
don't most of them don't care where
their ancestors are from they're just
vaguely European I don't really care and
the white identity has subsumed all of
these formerly super important
differences whereas the difference
between white and black as a socially
important category has has remained and
it seems to me the key difference it's
it's not that it's not that uh for
instance the bitterness between you know
Irish and British were any less real
they're you know huge but it's that when
people look the same or not the same but
when people look rather similar it's
easier for for them to blend over the
course of hundreds of years um in a way
way that it it just is harder when there
are actual uh you know color differences
does that seem like a fair analysis to
you there are a number of points here
the first is that if you go back to the
19th
century people saw the Irish with the
working class as physically distinct
sure um you know in a way we would find
it absurd today um that was the case um
so it's not the it's not purely the
question of looking different um that's
an issue here but it is true that that
um that the fact that black people are
easily distinguishable from whites plays
an important part in this one of the
reasons um that slavery was racialized
for instance at the end of say the the
17th century early 18th
century with it there were continual um
struggles against both slavery and
indentured servitude which is what um wh
poor whites faced in in in in America um
in those days um that blacks and whites
used to get together and and and and and
challenge their um enslavement or or
servitude and that uh it became easier
it was a lot easier to distinguish um
say a runaway slave if that slave was
black and if that slave was white and so
um partly to
to to break up that Coalition between
blacks and whites um slavery became
increasingly racialized you can see that
in America at the end of the 19th
century too when you had in the post
reconstruction world you had the fusion
movements between uh poor whites and
blacks um which challenged the the elite
um particularly in the south in uh North
and South Carolina in
um Virginia and so on um challenged them
um by by presenting a a broader U more
equal notion of what kind of society
they want to live in um The Challenge
particularly the the Democrats who were
who were the elites and and the
pro-slavery
um party in the South
um and in order to break up that
Coalition against quite deliberately in
order to break up that Coalition between
uh whites and blacks
um Jim Crow was introduced in a most
ferocious way to allow for certain types
of privileges for whites and to
segregate uh blacks um and so you can
see how racism becomes a means of uh of
breaking up uh cross cross racial
coalitions class coalitions um against
the
elites the idea of going back to to your
to your argument about uh about skin
color it's only in the early 20th
century that whiteness as we understand
it and Blackness as we understand it
became
Consolidated um the
what you call ethnic groups um the Irish
the slaves and so on um we see became
seen as whites um and that the major
division was purely between uh black and
white
um and there were two reasons for that
one was the extension expansion of
democracy within Western Nations so that
um the working class which should
largely been excluded from the
Democratic process we now brought in um
uh given the vote brought into
Democratic process and it became much
more difficult to talk about the working
classes racially uh inferior um when
they're part of the democratic process
and the second reason was the expansion
of
imperialism the new imperialism Scramble
for Africa um from the 18 uh 80s onwards
um
so so
that the Scramble for Africa divided up
Africa among the European nations um
America
seized
uh parts of the Pacific uh and so on um
and that's uh that new imperialism
redrew what uh Deo calls the color line
um and made race much more what as we
see it now um as a
uh issue of race issue of skin color of
a black and white issue um than it had
been
previously